LOVE.
HAVE A HAPPY, HEALTHY EVENING,
SEAN HANNITY IN NEW YORK
STANDING BY.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BIG BREAKING AND PERHAPS
HOPEFULLY, HOPEFULLY GAME
CHANGING NEWS TONIGHT.
THE RED TAPE WITH FDA, THE
PRESIDENT ACTING AT
UNPRECEDENTED SPEED AT AMERICA’S
TOP SCIENTISTS, MEDICAL
RESEARCHERS, DOCTORS WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK ON NEW, MAJOR
BREAK THROUGH WAYS TO TREAT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
ACTUALLY THE FDA APPROVED AND
ALREADY IN USE.
WE HAVE THESE INCREDIBLE DETAILS
COMING UP TONIGHT, THREE,
SEPARATE AREAS WE ARE WORKING ON
RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE ALSO IN THE MIDST OF THE
MAJOR WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC, SADLY,
THIS FULL-BLOWN GLOBAL CRISIS
MIGHT HAVE BEEN PREVENTED OR AT
LEAST MITIGATED IF NOT FOR THE
CORRUPT ACTIONS OF THE COMMUNIST
CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
ACCORDING TO THIS TOP STUDY FROM
A BRITISH UNIVERSITY, 95% OF ALL
CORONAVIRUS CASES THEY HAVE, IN
FACT, HAD BEEN PREVENTED HAD
CHINA NOT TRIED TO HIDE AND
COVER UP THIS DEADLY DISEASE AT
EVERY IMPORTANT MOMENT.
AND THE PRESIDENT INDICATED
EARLIER TODAY, HE HAD BEEN
SAYING IT REALLY MORE LOUDLY
THAN ANYONE I CAN THINK OF,
CHINA CANNOT BE TRUSTED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: CHINA,
THEY REPORTED FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE THE OUTBREAK, NO NEW CASES
OVER A 24-HOUR PERIOD.
DO YOU HAVE ANY REASON TO
DISBELIEVE THEM?
>> President Trump: AS FAR AS
WHAT THEY ARE PUTTING OUT NOW?
I HOPE IT IS TRUE BUT WHO KNOWS.
I HOPE IT IS TRUE.
>> ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT ANY
TYPE OF REPERCUSSIONS FOR CHINA,
AND ARE YOU ALSO THINKING THE
SUPPLY LINE FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS?
>> I DON’T WANT TO COMMENT ON
THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: YOU CAN’T TRUST
ANYTHING COMING FROM CHINA’S
GOVERNMENT SO THE FACTS AS EARLY
AS DECEMBER, HIGH-RANKING
CHINESE OFFICIALS, THEY ACTUALLY
SILENCED THE DOCTORS ON THE
FRONT LINE IN THE JOURNALIST.
IF YOU CAN EVEN SAY THEY HAVE
JOURNALIST, THEY DON’T HAVE
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS WHO BRAVELY
TRIED TO TELL THE TRUTH TO THE
ENTIRE WORLD, GIVE THE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION, VITAL INFORMATION
TO THE WORLD ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
HOW MANY OF THOSE DOCTORS WHO
PUT THEIR LIVES AT RISK ARE
DEAD?
THEY DIED TRYING TO SAVE OTHERS
IN THEIR COUNTRY WORLDWIDE.
AND ON JANUARY 18TH, THE DISEASE
WAS RAPIDLY SPREADING AND THE
WUJAN PROVINCE OF CHINA, THE
POTLUCK DINNER WITH TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ATTENDEES BEYOND
ITS INCOMPREHENSIBLE AND HOW
DUMB THAT IS.
UNTIL JANUARY 20TH, THE VIRUS
ALREADY SPREAD ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
CHINA ACTUALLY ADMITTED THE
DISEASE WAS CONTAGIOUS PERSON TO
PERSON.
NOW, THE 21ST OF JANUARY, WE HAD
OUR FIRST KNOWN CASE HERE, THE
31ST, TEN DAYS LATER.
AND I WILL GET TO THAT IN A
SECOND.
THIS IS THE KIND OF BOTCHED
CHERNOBYL-LIKE COVER UP SADLY
PREDICTABLE FOR COMMUNIST
GOVERNMENTS.
IT DOESN’T MEAN WE SHOULDN’T GET
ALONG WITH THEM, BUT WE NEED TO
KNOW THAT THEY ARE HOSTILE
ACTORS.
THEY DID NOT ACT ALONE.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO KNOW THIS,
THEY ARE A CORRUPT AND FRANKLY
USELESS ORGANIZATION, NOT UNLIKE
THE UNITED NATIONS IN MY
PERSPECTIVE.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE AN
ORGANIZATION THE WORLD COULD
TRUST, BUT INSTEAD, THEY HAVE
BEEN DOING AND ALL THEY HAVE
BEEN DOING IS SPREADING CHINESE
PARTY PROPAGANDA FROM DAY ONE.
THEY HAVEN’T DONE ANY
INDEPENDENT FACT-CHECKING.
AND THEY DESERVE BLAME FOR THIS
AS DOES CHINA.
LOOK AT THIS.
JANUARY 14TH, THAT IS LATE IN
THE GAME BY THIS POINT.
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION TWEETS
"CHINESE AUTHORITIES WITH NO
CLEAR EVIDENCE OF HUMAN TO HUMAN
TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS."
IF THEY HAD ANY SENSE, THEY
WOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT IS NOT
TRUE.
THEY HAVE DONE THEIR OWN
RESEARCH, THEY WOULD HAVE KNOWN
IN 5 MINUTES THAT IS NOT TRUE.
W.H.O.’S DIRECTOR AND GENERAL IN
CHIEF IS A SKETCHY INDIVIDUAL.
NO MEDICAL TRAINING.
HE HAS BEEN CARING CHINA’S WATER
FOR MONTHS ON THIS.
ACCORDING TO A BRAND-NEW REPORT
IN THE HILL TONIGHT HE TURNED A
BLIND EYE TO WHAT HAS HAPPENED
IN WUJAN AND REST OF CHINA AFTER
MEETING WITH PRESIDENT XI IN
JANUARY.
FROM THE OUTSET HE DEFENDED
CHINA DESPITE GROSS
MISMANAGEMENT OF THE HIGHLY
CONTAGIOUS DISEASE.
EVEN SUGGESTING THE PRESIDENT’S
TRAVEL BAN TO AND FROM CHINA WAS
A RACIST.
THAT ONE DECISION, HISTORY WILL
BEAR THIS OUT.
TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED CASE IN THIS COUNTRY,
JANUARY 21ST, 1ST CASE,
JANUARY 31ST, TRAVEL BAN.
THAT ONE DECISION DID MORE TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND LIVES OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS THAN ANY ONE
THING THAT HAS HAPPENED.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF MORE
AMERICANS WOULD HAVE CONTRACTED
THIS VIRUS, AND IT IS
INCALCULABLE HOW MANY MORE
AMERICANS WOULD HAVE DIED,
EXPONENTIALLY.
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN IN A FAR
WORSE POSITION THAN WE ARE IN
NOW.
HOW SAD IS YOUR MOB AND THE
MEDIA?
DO THEY EVER GIVE THE PRESIDENT
CREDIT?
IN RETROSPECT, THE PRESIDENT WAS
RIGHT WITH THAT.
DON’T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
SAME WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
AFTER JOE BIDEN, THAT VERY DAY
THE PRESIDENT IMPLEMENTED A
TRAVEL BAN, THIS IS WHAT HE HAD
TO SAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MOMENTS LIKE THIS, THIS IS
WHERE INCREDIBLY THE PRESIDENT
IS MOST NEEDED.
AND HE EXPLAINS WHAT WE SHOULD
AND SHOULD NOT DO.
THIS IS NO TIME FOR
DONALD TRUMP’S RECORD OF
HYSTERIA, XENOPHOBIA, HYSTERICAL
XENOPHOBIA AND FEARMONGERING TO
LEAD THE WAY INSTEAD OF SCIENCE.
>> Sean: HYSTERICAL
XENOPHOBIA, WAKE UP, JOE.
WHAT IS EVEN WORSE, EVEN KNOWING
WHAT WE NOW KNOW.
THIS IS EVEN WORSE.
YOU KNOW, DR. QUID PRO QUO SAYS
HE WOULD NOT HAVE IMPLEMENTED
THE BAND LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE
THIS MAN DOES, HE IS CLUELESS
WITH ZERO AWARENESS STUCK IN
THAT SWAMP STYLE THINKING AND
STUPIDITY!
AND THAT FRIEND OF IDENTITY
POLITICS IS LIKE THE NEW
FAVORITE TACTIC OF CHINA
PROPAGANDA DEPARTMENT WHICH IS
NOW WORKING OVERTIME TO DEFLECT.
OTHER FREQUENTLY MISUSED
INFORMATION AND CAMPAIGNS AND
CONSPIRACY THEORY, U.S. TROOPS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CHINESE
CORONAVIRUS.
THAT IS A LIE!
THAT IS AN OUT RIGHT LIE!
CHINA’S OPPRESSIVE REGIME CAUSED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS WORLDWIDE
TO GET SICK.
IT HAS CAUSED SICKNESS, DEAFNESS
AND DESTRUCTION FOR THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS MORE.
THEY MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
AND ANOTHER IT’S LAUGHABLE THAT
MORE PROPAGANDA, THEY ARE NOW
CLAIMING THEY ARE LEADING THE
WAY WORLDWIDE AND FIGHTING
AGAINST THE VIRUS EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT COVERED
IT UP ALL THESE MONTHS.
UNFORTUNATELY, SOME DEMOCRATS
AND OF COURSE THE GULLIBLE,
MEDIA MOB THAT HATES
PRESIDENT TRUMP SO MUCH,
THEY ARE ECHOING THESE
RIDICULOUS CHINESE LIES AND
PROPAGANDA, INCLUDING, YEAH,
FORMER OBAMA NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR, SUSAN RICE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CHINA IS NOT BEHAVING WELL
AND TRYING TO BLAME THIS ON THE
UNITED STATES.
BUT THE FLIP SIDE OF IT IS, WE
ARE NOT BEHAVING WELL WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT AS THE PRESIDENT DOES
EVERY DAY, THE CHINESE VIRUS,
THE WUJAN FLU AND ALL OF THESE
BASIC DESCRIPTIS.
>> Sean: REALLY, SUSAN?
SUSAN RICE, WHAT A SINGLE LEAST
TRUSTWORTHY INDIVIDUALS ON THE
FACE OF THE EARTH.
A NATIONAL DISGRACE!
REMEMBER ON SUNDAY SHOWS,
BLATANT LIES AFTER BENGHAZI
ATTACK.
THAT WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN.
GOOD RULE OF THUMB, SUSAN RICE,
WHATEVER SHE SAYS, BELIEVE THE
OPPOSITE BUT I DIGRESS.
THE MEDIA MOB THEY ARE NEW
FAVORITE HYSTERIA AROUND A
PICTURE FOR A "WASHINGTON POST"
PHOTOGRAPHER SHOWING UP CLOSE
SHOT OF THE PRESIDENT’S NOTES
WHERE CORONA IS CROSSED OUT AND
REPLACED WITH CHINESE.
THIS IS INSIDE AN ARTICLE
SUGGESTING HE WAS USING RACISM
AGAINST CHINA TO TRY TO DISTRACT
THE PRESIDENT’S DISASTROUS
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE.
FAKE NEWS CNN CALL DATE AND
ACCURATE.
STIGMATIZING THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS WILL BE SICK AND DIED.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE FOCUSED
ON?
REALLY?
WE HAVE ALL SORTS OF DISEASES
AND WE LAID THEM OUT LAST NIGHT.
NAME THE LOCATION WERE
DISCOVERED.
MORE LYING TO THE VIEWERS
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, THE AGENDA
IS TO AID THE PRESIDENT.
EVEN THOUGH WILLIE DUKES WITH
CHINESE PROPAGANDA.
IT IS PATHETIC.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD A MESSAGE
FOR HIS FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA
MOB.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHY DOES THE UNITED STATES
NOT PREPARE?
>> WE WERE PREPARED TO.
THE ONLY THING WE WERE NOT
PREPARED FOR WAS THE MEDIA.
THE MEDIA HAS NOT TREATED IT
FAIRLY.
I WILL TELL YOU, I CALLED FOR A
PAN FOR PEOPLE COMING INTO CHINA
LONG BEFORE ANYBODY THOUGHT
IT WAS, IN FACT, IT WAS YOUR
NETWORK, I BELIEVE THEY CALLED
ME A RACIST BECAUSE I DID THAT.
IT WAS MANY OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM, THEY CALLED ME RACIST IN
OTHER WORDS BECAUSE I DID THAT,
BECAUSE I WENT SO EARLY.
SO YOU SAID WE WERE NOT PREPARED
TO.
HAD I LEFT THESE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE COME FROM
CHINA A DAY, WE WOULD HAVE HAD
SOMETHING RIGHT NOW THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN, YOU WOULD NOT EVEN
RECOGNIZE IT COMPARED TO WHERE
WE ARE.
>> Sean: EXTREMELY WELL SAID.
HERE ARE SOME FACTS THE MOB
WON’T REPORT.
YOU KNOW, THE ONES
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," I LOVE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
TRUMP IRIS, IF YOU FEEL AWFUL,
YOU KNOW WHO TO BLAME.
IN THE PRESIDENT, THE PRESIDENT
SAYS YOU ARE ON YOUR OWN.
HE SAID YOU CAN DO IT FASTER.
THEY FORGOT THAT PART.
THAT IS CALLED EDITED FAKE NEWS.
THANKS TO THE PRESIDENT’S
DECISIVE ACTION THE NEW
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SET.
I CALL THIS A PARADIGM SHIFT.
GOING FORWARD, FUTURE PANDEMICS,
UNFORTUNATELY THEY POP UP BUT I
WISH THEY DIDN’T.
TRAVEL BAN’S TO SLOW THE SPREAD
OF THE DISEASE.
BECAUSE IT SAVES LIVES OF
AMERICANS.
THIS SUCCESS IS THE PRESIDENT’S
PRIVATE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP
SURROUNDING TESTING, AND OTHER
NEW MASSIVE PARADIGM SHIFT.
THEY ARE DOING ALL OF THIS ON
THE FLY IN RECORD TIME.
KEEPING PEOPLE OUT OF HOSPITALS.
THAT WILL BE HOW THINGS WORK
GOING FORWARD.
TELEMEDICINE.
MY SON HAS A FEVER.
MY DAUGHTER HAS A FEVER.
TAKE A LOOK AT MY SON OR
DAUGHTER.
WHAT DO I DO?
DO I NEED TO GO TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM?
NOT NOW, CALL ME BACK IN AN HOUR
AND FACE TIME AGAIN.
NOW THE UNITED STATES ACTIVELY
LOOKING TO DECREASE DEPENDENCY
ON IMPORTANT GOODS AND MEDICINES
MANUFACTURED IN CHINA.
YOU KNOW WHAT, WE CAN’T AFFORD
TO RISK THIS ANY FURTHER.